[Applaus]
[Musik]
am dienstag dem 26 april 2022 fand auf
der us airbase im pfälzischen ramstein
eine der bedeutendsten internationalen
gipfelkonferenzen der letzten jahre
statt mehr als 40 verbündete länder
kamen zusammen um der ukraine jede
notwendige militärische unterstützung
zuzusichern mit der sie den ansturm der
russischen invasionstruppen
zurückschlagen kann allein in den ersten
zwei monaten seit beginn der invasion
haben die verbündeten mehr als fünf
milliarden dollar an militärhilfe an die
ukraine geliefert
niemand lässt sich von putins
fadenscheinigen gründen oder seinen
falschen behauptungen über den
bombastischen russlands invasion ist
nicht zu rechtfertigen genauso wie die
russischen gräueltaten nationen guten
willens aus der ganzen welt sind sich
einig in ihrer entschlossenheit die
ukraine in ihrem kampf gegen die
imperiale aggression russlands zu
unterstützen lloyd austin us
verteidigungsminister meine lieben
besucher politik zuschauer die große
invasion hat nicht nur solidarität mit
der ukraine ausgelöst sondern auch eines
sehr deutlich gemacht tyrannen kann man
nicht trauen schon gar nicht aus so
feindlich gesinnten ländern wie russland
man muss sich eben auf den krieg bzw die
verteidigung gegen diesen vorbereiten
wenn man ist mit dem frieden wirklich
ernst meint ein grundprinzip dass nur
praktisch wieder klar denken die
menschen in allen verbündeten ländern
begriffen hat von deutschland über japan
bis australien
deutsche verteidigungs investitionen
werden die neuverschuldung im jahr 2022
verdoppeln wie der ukraine krieg japan
verändert tokio bewegt sich auf eine
selbstbewusstere sicherheitsstrategie zu
aber gerade in den ländern des
ehemaligen warschauer paktes dass diese
erkenntnis auf den fruchtbarsten wohnen
wenn wir das schlimmste nämlich krieg
vermeiden wollen müssen wir nach der
alten regel handeln die besagt wenn du
frieden willst bereite dich auf den
krieg vor jaroslaw kaczynski
stellvertretende ministerpräsident
polens und vorsitzender der ps praktisch
alle mittel und mittel osteuropäischen
länder haben erkannt dass sie sich auf
einen krieg vorbereiten müssen und genau
da setzen sie nun konsequent und
blitzschnell um allen voran schreitet
jedoch ein land das sich allmählich zu
einer einflussreichen jahr führenden
europäischen markt entwickelt gegen
welche die alten taktgeber der eu immer
besser dastehen heute werden wir uns
deswegen dieses aufstrebende land genau
ansehen was es mit ihm auf sich hat und
wohin es europa führende
[Musik]
ein führender akteur im wahrsten sinne
des wortes
als die sowjetunion anfang der 1990 er
jahre zusammen brach weil die neue
unabhängige ukraine und das viele
überraschend eine der wirtschaftlich
wohlhabendsten postkommunistischen
staaten also gut ich meine wohlhabende
mieter des sowjetischen kontextes denn
die wahrheit ist dass alles was aus der
ehemaligen sowjetunion vorgängen ein
heilloses chaos war dennoch war das
preisbereinigte pro kopf bip der ukraine
etwa 20 prozent höher als das puls und
wenn diese differenz das heute erhalten
geblieben wäre und die ukraine es
geschafft hätte einen ebenso effektiven
politischen und wirtschaftlichen
übergang wie polen oder tschechien zu
vollziehen entspreche die ukrainische
wirtschaft heute fast zwei drittel der
russischen aber wie wir alle wissen
verlief die geschichte natürlich ganz
anders
[Musik]
die drei jahrzehnte der ukrainischen
unabhängigkeit waren geprägt von
wirtschaftlicher stagnation innere
spaltung oder einem institutionellen
verfall der die ukraine zum ärmsten land
in ganz europa machte die krise war so
groß dass die ukrainische wirtschaft bis
2005 nicht über das niveau von 1989
hinaus kam und diese misere war eine der
voraussetzungen für die russische
invasion der krim die abspaltung des
sommers und später für die invasion des
ganzen landes in den letzten zehn jahren
haben sich die dinge in der ukraine
jedoch stark verändert und kiew konnte
einen wichtigen und mächtigen partner
für die umsetzung dieses ganzen
reformprozesses finden von denen jede
rede ist natürlich von polen
[Musik]
im letzten jahrzehnt war polen
vielleicht das land das die politische
wirtschaftliche und sogar kulturelle
entwicklung der ukraine am stärksten
beeinflusst hat es war seine minister
unterstützer innerhalb der europäischen
union und der nato ist nahm vor der
invasion mehr als 1,5 millionen
ukrainische unbekannten auf und gab
diesem land ein modell um den sprung auf
den zug der gesellschaftlichen und
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung zu schaffen
wir sprechen über zwei länder mit sehr
engen auch historischen beziehungen
zueinander tatsächlich waren sie
jahrhundertelang teil der polnisch
litauischen union und in jüngerer zeit
lehnten sie gemeinsam die sowjetische
besatzung gab es kann weder ein freies
polen ohne eine freie ukraine noch eine
freie ukraine ohne ein freies polen
geben polnische volksweisheit nun nach
dem russischen überfall auf die ukraine
ist polen zu einem der hauptakteure in
den politischen nachrichten geworden und
auch das land das die europäischen
kriegsvorbereitungen anfühlt und was
genau das zu bedeuten hat sehen wir uns
jetzt ganz genau an
die neue macht paulo dias
[Musik]
der angriff russlands auf die ukraine
hat polen also zu einem der hauptakteure
in der krise gemacht das land das
zusammen mit den vereinigten staaten und
großbritannien die ukraine am stärksten
unterstützt warum liefert und
hunderttausende millionen von
flüchtlingen aufnimmt allein in den
ersten drei wochen nach der russischen
invasion nach polen mehr als zwei
millionen flüchtlinge auf und damit ihr
euch eine vorstellung davon machen
können praktisch über nacht landete das
land auf der welt rangliste der länder
mit den meisten aufgenommen flüchtlingen
auf platz vier hinter der türkei
kolumbien und den usa
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seit beginn des krieges haben die
polnische regierung und die ganze
polnische zivilgesellschaft ein beispiel
um das system aus unterkünften
transportmitteln lebensmittelversorgung
psychologischer unterstützung und hilfe
aller art aufgebaut die polnische
regierung zahlen sogar kleine monatliche
zuwendungen an familien die aus der
ukraine gekommen sind um ihnen das leben
zu erleichtern
flüchtlinge dürfen aber vor allem im
land nach arbeit suchen und sie wurden
auch ins gesundheits und bildungssystem
aufgenommen zehntausende ukrainischer
kinder gehen bereits auf polnische
schulen wir sprechen hier von einer
gigantischen anstrengung und
gleichzeitig eine gigantische chance für
die polnische wirtschaft der die ukraine
sind in der regel gut ausgebildet und
fleißig zählen allgemein zu den eher
emanzipations affinen migrantengruppen
und das ist noch nicht alles polen ist
auch zum einfallstor für westlichen
waffen nur die lieferungen in die
ukraine uns an der wichtigsten
politischen akteure der gegenwart
geworden der ukraine krieg macht polen
zu amerikas unverzichtbaren verbündeten
mit anderen worten polen ist plötzlich
zu einem der größten widersacher von
putin russland geworden und ist ein
paradebeispiel für den erfolg im
militärischen wettlauf
der pole ist dabei seine streitkräfte
von etwa 110.000 soldaten auf rund
250.000 zu verdoppeln und gleichzeitig
eine der modernsten armeen europas
werden es ist ein außergewöhnlicher und
historischer moment die einführung
polens in eine völlig neue welt von
spitzentechnologie moderner waffen und
verteidigungsmaßnahmen antreten
präsident polens denkel dürfen nicht
vergessen dass polen eine direkte grenze
zu russland hat nämlich bei kaliningrad
und natürlich auch zu putins engsten
militärischen verbündeten weißrussland
von diesen wurde es ja bereits vor dem
krieg durch einen organisierten und
instrumentalisierten migranten an strom
angegriffen wir haben darüber ein video
gedreht das ich euch verlinken werde
schließlich ist polen immer wieder eines
der beliebtesten ziele direkter gewalt
und krieg sun drohungen aus dem kreml
erst jüngst regte duma-abgeordnete oleg
morosow auf der für putins partei
einiges russland im parlament ist
designer telegramm gruppe an polen
sondern nach der entnazifizierung der
ukraine gleich als nächstes land auf
russlands spezialoperation liste gesetzt
werden
es ist daher überhaupt nicht
verwunderlich dass polen eines der
wenigen europäischen länder ist dessen
militärhaushalt die von der nato als
mindestziel gesetzten 2 prozent des bip
übersteigt und es war schon lange bevor
die school war und im oktober 2021
kündigte der stellvertretende polnische
ministerpräsident jaroslaw kaczynski der
heimliche herrscher polen sogar an das
land wolle seine militärausgaben auf
mindestens drei prozent des bip erhöhen
auf diese weise will die polnische
regierung nicht nur die größe ihrer
streitkräfte mehr als verdoppeln sondern
auch ihre territorialen
verteidigungskräfte ausbauen eine
unterstützungs armee aus freiwilligen
soldaten außerdem wird sie ihr
waffenarsenal stark modernisieren indem
sie kampfsystem aus dass derzeit durch
modernere nato kompatibel ausrüstung
ersetzt große teile dieser nachricht
gewartet nun ist das bereits ein alten
bestände landen nun in der ukraine aber
was man ihr gibt es einen besseren
zeitpunkt um mal ordentlich aufzuräumen
die polnische armee verfügt zb noch über
etwa 500 t 72 panzer als die offensive
begann und in der polnischen luftwaffe
gibt es immer noch einige mit 29 und 22
und nun deutet alles darauf hin dass
sich diese situation sehr bald ändern
wird nicht nur wegen der
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine juli
2021 kündigte die polnische regierung zb
den kauf von 250 us amerikanischen
apples konstant um die 250 leopard 2 zu
ergänzen die sie bereits in ihrem
bestand hat ein weiteres beispiel ist
die alternde luftwaffe des landes in den
letzten zehn jahren ist die zahl der
einsatzfähigen kampfjets in polen von
128 auf 98 gesunken um hier abhilfe zu
schaffen kündigte die regierung im jahr
2020 ein 4,6 milliarden dollar deal an
der 32 s 35 umfasst die 2024 geliefert
werden sollen im selben jahr erwartet
sie auch ein flugabwehrsystem vom typ
patriot für 4,8 milliarden dollar und im
mai 2021 kam 24 türkische bayraktar tb2
drohen in so einer der derzeitigen
schlüsseldaten der ukrainischen streits
erste und einer der schlimmsten
albträume russischer panzerbesatzung
alles in allem ist das aber nur ein
tropfen auf den heißen stein um seine
streitkräfte zu modernisieren wird polen
in den nächsten jahren große haushalts
technische anstrengung unternehmen
müssen zu welchen die regierung jedoch
mehr als bereit zu sein scheint und das
sagen nicht nur wir sondern auch der
stellvertretende ministerpräsident und
vorsitzender der regierungspartei hdz
kaczynski selbst es ist besser
sicherheit zu haben und sich dafür ein
bisschen mehr zu verschulden jaroslaw
kaczynski stellvertretende
ministerpräsident polens eines ist also
klar polen gibt in europa verteidigungs
und sicherheitspolitisch bereits heute
die marschrichtung vor und der große
rest folgt so schnell er kann der
einstige motor der eu die achse berlin
paris ist nur noch mit deutlich hörbarem
getriebeschaden unterwegs den sie sich
selbst durch die unsachgemäße nutzung
des rückwärtsgangs eingebrockt hat
aufgepasst
[Musik]
der seit knapp
mit ausnahme ungarns über das wir bald
ein eigenes video drehen werden ist man
sich in ganz mittel und mittelosteuropa
vollkommen einig niemand traut mehr
moskau auch nur einen finger bereit über
den weg mehr noch aufgrund der offen zur
schau gestellten opportunistischen
unzuverlässigkeit der beiden mächte
deutschland und frankreich wird selbst
die zugehörigkeit zur nato nicht mehr
als ausreichender schutz angesehen auf
die ein oder andere weise fand also fast
alle länder in dieser region an sich
aufzuraffen um impuls zu staates zu
treten ein gutes beispiel dafür ist
tschechien ein land für das
verteidigungsausgaben in den vergangenen
jahren nicht gerade eine priorität waren
da es sich im schuss seines großen
nachbarn deutschland lehnte im jahr 2022
wurden beispielsweise nur schlappe 1,35
prozent des bip für die verteidigung
veranschlagt und diese werk schon ein
deutlicher sprung gegenüber den 0,95
prozent die sie 2015 ausgegeben haben
aber all das klingt wie ein märchen aus
einer anderen zeit
die tschechische regierung hat
angekündigt dass sie ihre militärbudget
bis 2025 um 60 prozent erhöhen will auch
bulgarien rumänien und die baltischen
republiken kündigen erhebliche
erhöhungen ihrer militärbudgets an
rumänien den verteidigungsausgaben auf
2,5 prozent des bip erhöhen estland
lettland und litauen werden ihre
militärausgaben auf deutlich
über eine milliarde euro für waffen aus
den usa und deutschland ausgehen
allerdings geht es bei der
kriegsvorbereitung nicht nur um
militärausgaben oder politische
beziehungen es gibt noch viele weitere
variablen die wir berücksichtigen müssen
eine davon eine sehr wichtige ist die
infrastruktur ist macht euch überraschen
aber diese kann im ernstfall ein kriegs
entscheidende schwachpunkt sein
um einen krieg zu gewinnen oder eine
glaubhafte und wirksame abschreckung
strategie zu verfolgen brauchst du nicht
nur eine armee du musst die auch bewegen
und versorgen können genau aus diesem
grund oder 2021 die connecting europe
facility vereinbart ein
finanzierungsinstrument der europäischen
union das 1 7 milliarden dollar zur
verbesserung der militärischen mobilität
bereich stellt allerdings sprechen der
über ein sehr knappes budget in einer
zeit in der der krieg deutlich gemacht
hat dass diese art von
präventivmaßnahmen notwendig ist mit der
russische invasion in der ukraine wurde
dieses thema natürlich zu einer
absoluten priorität straßen und
eisenbahn infrastruktur brücken häfen
und flughäfen werden nun fit für den
verteidigungsfall gemacht so ausgebaut
und mit allem ausgestattet damit falls
nötig eine große zahl von truppen
schnell an die front verlegt werden kann
[Musik]
es handelt sich um einen der wichtigsten
faktoren im rahmen der kaltstart
fähigkeit unserer streitkräfte und
betrifft besonders dringend das östliche
mitteleuropa wo viele wichtige
infrastruktur elemente wie brücken den
gewichten amerikanische britische oder
deutscher panzer nicht standhalten
können in europa hat man die ansicht
vertreten dass wir keine ausgaben für
die verteidigung brauchen seit dem 24
februar als russland die ukraine
angegriffen hat hat sich diese ansicht
komplett geändert eines der projekte das
am meisten beschleunigt werden können da
ist zum beispiel rail baltica eine 5,8
milliarden euro teuren normalen spurige
eisenbahnverbindungen die estland
lettland und litauen mit polen verbinden
soll es handelt sich um absolut
unverzichtbare infrastruktur mit welcher
sichergestellt wird dass große
truppenbewegungen schnell durchgeführt
werden können im rahmen des finnischen
aufnahmeantrags für die nato gibt es
sogar überlegungen diese strecke von
island nach finnland durch einen tunnel
unter dem meer zu verlängern und das ist
nur die spitze des eisbergs durch die
rasche nato-erweiterung die putin
ausgelöst hat könnte erwarten dass noch
viele weitere militärische infrastruktur
projekte ordentlich an fahrt aufnehmen
werden denn die idee stellt
infrastruktur eine sehr wichtige
komponente da sich auf den krieg
vorzubereiten und europas
abschreckungsstrategie zu verbessern
europa wird zu einer festung ausgebaut
und der geist der wehrhaftigkeit und
resilienz dürfte aus dem militärischen
bald auch in alle anderen
gesellschaftlichen bereiche durchsickern
polen gibt auch hierbei wieder den ton
an bringt es doch schließlich wie andere
länder in der region eine menge
historisches rüstzeug mit durch welches
es wird diese führungsrolle geradezu
prädestiniert ist die geschichte lehrt
uns immer wieder dass ein militärischer
sieg nicht immer auch einen
geopolitischen sieg bedeuten muss
manchmal wird krieg einfach immer nur in
die niederlage egal was auf dem
schlachtfeld passiert
die erfahrungen der usa in afghanistan
im irak machen dies ebenso deutlich wie
in moskaus eigene erfahrungen mit den
einmarsch in ungarn 1956 in überfall der
tschechoslowakei 1968 und der verhängung
des kriegsrechts in polen
1981 in all diesen fällen war der
triumph auf den schlachtfeldern nicht
gleichbedeutend mit einem sieg im
gegenteil bei den militärischen triumph
handelt es sich um reine bio siegel
durch welche die sowjetunion die herzen
der menschen noch weiter verlor ja die
sowjetunion hat den kalten krieg damals
eigentlich bereits verloren da sie nicht
einmal in der lage war ihre eigenen
verbündeten aus dem warschauer pakt zu
vereinen und für sich zu gewinnen
tatsächlich haben sich die russen selbst
durch ihre militärische interventionen
all diesen fällen bei den tschechischen
polnischen und auch viel ungarischen
bürger immer weiter verhasst gemacht
die vws hatten nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg der sie an der seite
nazi-deutschland selbst losgetreten
hatten zunächst die großartige chance
ihre fatalen fehler zu korrigieren und
als wahre befreier so gelten doch diese
chance erstickten sie durch ihren hang
zur tyrannei und herrschsucht daher wird
unabhängig davon was auf den
schlachtfeldern der ukraine passiert der
dortige krieg wieder genau das gegenteil
dessen bewirken was moskau eigentlich
beabsichtigt die distanz das misstrauen
und die feindseligkeit der ukraine
gegenüber russland werden nun auf
generationen hinweg in die sowieso schon
vom holodomor traumatisierte volksseele
eingebrannt und das gleiche gilt auch
für die übrigen völker in der region
russland ist für so gut wie alle seine
nachbarn zu einem schimpfwort geworden
ein symbol für terror und menschlichkeit
und unverbesserliche gesellschaftliche
rückständigkeit es hat sich damit
endgültig aus dem kulturkreis des
europäischen humanismus verabschiedet
die nato hingegen wird stärker
geschlossener besser vorbereitet und mit
neun mitgliedern aus all dieser not
hervorgehen über all das werden wir bald
hier auf diese politik sprechen denn
wenn es putins absicht gewesen sein
sollte die nato zu spalten und weniger
geeint gegen russland aufzutreten hat er
das genaue gegenteil erreicht russland
wird nun eine viel längere grenze mit
viel stärker bewaffneten und befestigten
nachbarn haben jahrelang hat es versucht
seine ehemaligen was allen staaten aus
dem warschauer pakt einzuschüchtern doch
nun hatte sie endgültig dazu ermutigt
russlands selbständig gegenüber zu
treten und in die augen zu schauen und
polen wird durch diese nicht mehr zu
stoppen dynamik so eine continental
macht aufsteigen
[Musik]
ja es hat die totale motivation und auch
das zeug dazu russland sowohl
militärisch als auch wirtschaftlich ganz
alleine zu übertrumpfen und sg dieses
ziel konsequent an sozusagen auch als
späte genugtuung für das erlittene
trauma jenes uhr trauma das die sowjets
zusammen mit hitler deutschland dem land
zugefügt haben durch ihren
hinterhältigen überfall und die
zahlreichen kriegsverbrechen wie zum
beispiel das massaker von katyn und wenn
wir einen preis für die absurdeste
hinaus ist und kontraproduktiv sste
politische idee des letzten jahrzehnts
vergeben sollten wäre es schwer einen
besseren kandidaten als putin mit einer
abscheuliche invasion der ukraine zu
finden er hat das antlitz europas für
immer verändert und zwar in jenes das
ihm von allen möglichen am
allerwenigsten gefällt das
machtgleichgewicht hat sich so
gewissermaßen nach osten verschoben aber
ganz ganz anders als sich putin und
seine fünfte kolonne in der eu
ausgerechnet haben über diese neue
zukunftsregion die neue mitte europas
werden wir noch so manches video drehen
vergesst also bitte nicht das abo und
noch viel wichtiger das glöckchen und
keines dieser videos zu verpassen die
bedeutung dieser länder wird nicht nur
aufgrund ihrer eigenen entschlossenheit
und energie enorm steigen sondern auch
weil nach der befreiung und
stabilisierung der ukraine das
gebeutelte land und seine nachbarin
einen unvergleichlichen aufhol und
erneuerungsprozess einen gigantischen
buch erleben durften unsere prognose aus
den vorletzten video gemäß der polen gar
die wirtschaftskraft russlands das vier
mal mehr einwohner hat überholen könnte
ist angesichts dieses szenarios so gar
nicht mal so unrealistisch überlegt
markt war die russische volkswirtschaft
im jahr 2014 noch viermal so groß wie
kohls so erreichte die polnische
wirtschaftsleistung durch sieben jahre
später bereits 40 prozent der russlands
und dürfte nun nach den kriegs eindruck
die 50 prozent marke gerissen haben aber
an dieser stelle muss ich noch unbedingt
mit einem weit verbreiteten vorurteil
aufräumen welches in den kommentaren zu
besagten video aufkamen nein der grund
für dieses enorme wachstum polen sind
nicht allein eu-subventionen die
europäische integration hat polen
tschechien der slowakei ungarn anderen
staaten es war eine produktive
wirtschaft und viele jobs gebracht das
problem ist jedoch die gewinne ihrer
wirtschaft fließen zu einem sehr großen
teil in den westen ab und in der summe
übersteigen diese dividenden abschlüsse
nach westeuropa zumeist nach deutschland
sogar die staatlichen transfers aus dem
eu-haushalt bei weitem und das schon
seit jahren zwischen 2010 und 2016 hat
polen 4,7 prozent seiner
wirtschaftsleistung als kapitaleinkommen
gen westen geschickt und zugleich nur
2,7 prozent netto aus dem eu haushalt
erhalten noch ungünstiger fällt die
bilanz für ungarn und tschechien aus die
ungarn überweisen ganze 72 prozent ihres
bip gen westen und bekommen nur vier
prozent zurück die tschechen und jetzt
haltet euch fest in tschechien drücken
sage und schreibe 7,6 prozent ab und
bekommen dafür normale 1,9 prozent die
ware nettozahler der eu sind also ganz
klar diese staaten mittel- und
mittelosteuropas und während die
ungleichheit innerhalb dieser länder
relativ gering bleibt entsteht ein
kolonial ähnliches verhältnis zur
ausländischen oberschicht der polnische
tschechische slowakische und ungarische
facharbeiter mal luft also als
leistungsträger für ein drittel oder die
hälfte des gehalts eines
westeuropäischen kollegen damit die
deutschen französischen und
niederländischen aktionäre mega profite
abräumen dürfen und wie gesagt wir reden
hier nicht von peanuts sondern von
milliardenbeträgen die durchaus einen
beträchtlichen teil dieser
volkswirtschaften ausmachen gut diesen
mythos hätten wir also klar gestellt
aber jetzt ist erst mal eure meinung
gefragt was haltet ihr von den plänen
aufstiegschancen dieser mittel und
osteuropäischen länder glaubt ihr dass
polen sich irgendwann zu einer
vollwertigen führenden europäischen
markt entwickeln wird welche weiteren
erfolgsfaktoren könnt ihr identifizieren
und welche sollten wir näher analysieren
sollte der rest europas denn bei spielt
dieser länder folgen die immer sind wir
schon auf eure beiträge im
kommentarbereich gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses video gefallen hat und hier
vielleicht noch etwas war bei gelernt
habt falls ja gibt es mit einem live
chat mit freunden und vergesst nicht
dass ab mit glöckchen und keines unserer
videos mehr zu verpassen natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
spende von euch mit der er uns helfen
dieses projekt weiterzuführen denn peter
link dazu findet ihr in der beschreibung
unter dem video was gut und bis bald
[Musik]